introducing ryan rosario to talk about a
sentiment at at facebook with some of
their data for the quick rundown on
ryan's by oh he's a quant engineer at
facebook working on machine learning and
natural language processing before
facebook he used to work down in a los
angeles near me at a doing machine
learning and NLP involving real-time
bidding he holds a PhD in stats and MS
in CS from UCLA and Ryan's been coding
in Python since 2005 when he started
using it for web crawling and web graph
mining he's a recovering our user though
he's still a fan most the time well
we'll see we can pull them or keep them
on our side for the rest the day so with
no further ado Ryan thank you thank you
for coming today
today I'm gonna be talking about some
experiments and proof-of-concept work
that we've done here at Facebook around
sentiment analysis so the outline of my
talk is basically I'm going to spend
some time talking a little bit about
sentiment analysis and current
approaches and then I'll start talking
about approaches that we've tried and
our current approach and then I'll talk
about the Python ecosystem and how we
use the sentiment analysis I have a
little bit of code that I want to show
it's very short because scikit-learn
makes this very easy but there's a lot
of infrastructure stuff that goes into
this as well every two months at
Facebook we host a hackathon and
sometimes it's hackathons the themes
sometimes were free to do or whatever we
would like for hackathon project and
about a month after leaving bootcamp I
decided to I've been working on NLP
stuff I decided well what if we try to
do some sentiment analysis with some
text so that was my hackathon project
and it ended up getting pretty good
results on in using NLT Kay and we
decided to end up using this as my
full-time project for now at least so
without further ado I'll just jump into
this so sentiment classification and
analysis what we want to do is take a
piece of text we want to do one of two
things with it we want to either say
what the emotion is that the person was
feeling
when they wrote the text or we want to
get a general sense for how they felt
when they wrote the text what was it
meant to be positive or was it meant to
be negative or something else in this
stuff though I'm not going to focus on
detecting emotions we're just going to
talk about general sentiment so it's
something positive or is it something
negative here's an example of some text
that can be inspired by a positive
emotion so the sentence I love Justin
Bieber is kind of a sense that appears
here a lot if you work here at Facebook
you know what I'm talking about so the
word love is probably or at least
statistically probably speaking up
meaning that this is a positive most
positively emotive sense but one thing
that's interesting to note here is that
the bigram Justin Bieber a bigram being
two words next to each other could also
have a sentiment of its own we won't
focus on that here
however Justin Bieber could have a
positive sentiment or a negative
sentiment depending on who's saying this
now if this could depend on gender it
could depend on age group and it could
depend on geography I'm not exactly sure
what Canadians think of Justin Bieber
but we won't go there some texts can
also have a negative context so I'm from
Southern California and I really hate
the rain so the word hate probably
invokes negative sentiment now of course
the word rain can also have its own
sentiment related to it depending on
geography for example here in California
we're in the middle of a pretty large
bad drought right now so the word rain
could be positive whenever I hear the
word rain it's negative it could also
depend on the time also it could be a
temporal sentiment so during an El Nino
season when we get a ton of rain it
could be a negative thing because the
floods and all that type of stuff now
there's a couple of cases that I don't
currently take into account but they're
very interesting to look at one case is
where a sentence has mixed emotion so
this is where you have two thoughts in
one sense part of the sentence positive
part of it negative so I really like the
actors but the plot was boring so
as is life people are often very
conflicted this type of sentence is what
I call a mixed sense and here parsing
the sentence can be more useful than
just analyzing the words in the sentence
and finally there's the case where text
is not inspired by any sentiment or
emotion
these are usual usually effects Barack
Obama is the 43rd President of the
United States and I remember I told
myself I wanted to check that that was
in fact he's in fact the 43rd but we're
just going to go with that and these are
often called objective texts whereas
something that has a sentimental notions
is subjective so now I'm going to talk a
little bit about some current sentiment
analysis approaches both what we tried
and general analysis methods so some
methods are based on dictionaries or
lexicon base other methods are machine
learning based everything that's on this
slide here is a lexicon based method
sent a word net CENTAC net word net
effect and Li WC which apparently is
pronounced Luke which is linguistic
inquiry and word count so for my talk
I'm dividing these into two groups
there's a second group and that is
machine learning or using a machine
learning model for this so you can use
standard machine learning techniques
such as SVM naive Bayes decision tree
whatever seems to work and they're
frequently use in a supervised setting
and the features that are typically used
for these models are say the ratio of
positive words the negative words maybe
the count of positive words and negative
words although a ratio is usually better
or something more interesting or lexical
features like quantity quantifiers and
negations so in an English sense a
negation is just the word no or not
which flips to sentiment a sentence or
you can have quantifiers which is which
are words like 2 or very that either
diminish or exaggerate the sentiment of
the sentence one method that's gained a
lot of traction or one piece of
literature I should say that has gained
a lot of traction comes out of Stanford
as usual and the author of this
sososo chair Sacher from Stanford came
up with this deep learning technique
so deep learning that's kind of a hot
new thing and machine learning everybody
wants to use it everybody says they're
using it so Stanford of course is taking
the lead and they've created their own
sentiment classifier that gets between
or 80% and 85% accuracy and it combines
bag of words so if you're not familiar
with that terminology it means we just
look at words we don't look at anything
else the words that I'm staying are just
a stream of consciousness basically
that's a bag of words representation but
they also use lexical features so
they're using for example parsing the
sentence in two different clusters
depending on how the the writer author
or speaker intended it to be interpreted
but data that they use for this is
called the Stanford sentiment tree Bank
it's hand labelled by three human judges
so basically these people took a bunch
of sentences they diagram them out and
they had some list of features or some
list of words that maps to a particular
sentiment positive or negative each atom
which is a word in this case atoms can
be other things as well but we're going
to we're going to say their words or
they are words in this research and
they're labeled with a positive
sentiment negative or no sentiment at
all this graphic is basically what they
do so they divide the sentence into a
tree structure and each leaf node of
this tree is a word in that sentence so
this full sense is this this film
doesn't care about cleverness wit or any
other kind of intelligent humor so some
of these leaf nodes some of these words
have positive sentiment some of them
have no sentiment and some are very
positive but when you bubble these these
words up into the parent node there's a
model that takes into account the the
lexical structure of the leaf nodes and
how they combine in to form a set into
to form a sentiment for that part for
that subtree of the sense and this is
called the recursive oral network they
call their method or recursive neural
tensor Network and really the reason why
I mentioned this is just because it's
kind of the hot literature right now and
I won't go into any further discussion
about this method this method is not
particularly scalable and data is scarce
so I believe they use something like ten
thousand examples and they had humans
judge each sentence
which gets me to my next point
sentiment analysis is very difficult and
it's difficult for several reasons and
it also varies on the language we're
talking about people are complex but so
is the language that people use an ideal
sentiment analysis takes this structure
into account one classic example is the
phrase this is not a very good day
there's a lot going on in the sentence
although our brains truly determine what
the sentence means and that's a negative
sentiment sense so although an ideal
algorithm takes a sentence structure
into account we can do a pretty good job
without it and that's the point of the
model in this talk that we'll discuss so
in the in the phrase this is not a very
good day for example we have words like
knot which induce nesting in the sense
you need to know where the knot part
begins and where the knot part ends and
this will flip the sentiment of whatever
is within that nesting so if you say I'm
not happy today my car broke down the
phrase happy today my car broke down
maybe because of the word happy it may
be determined be positive but the word
not will flip that sentiment which is
something that a bag of words model
can't really take into account by its
nature words like very and to also
exaggerate the sentiment but also and
more difficult is that some by grams
like not very aren't not very
transparent see what I'd see what I did
there so as an example I'm not very
hungry that doesn't mean I'm not it
doesn't mean what it says essentially
it's a softer form of I'm not hungry
do you want it do you want to go to the
bar well I might say not really but it
means no I don't some other things that
are very difficult with sentiment
analysis is that emotions may not
translate across languages so it's
difficult to come up with an example of
that but for example one example I'll
use later is the word hot so the word
hot can mean I'm really warm which is
not really warm in here or it could mean
somebody that's very attractive in the
English language that's true in other
languages you might not have that
distinction hot may only refer to a
temperature also sarcasm and humor are
never handled well in an NLP system
there might be some research
about this but in general you can't
build a very good model that models
humor or sarcasm also is the subjunctive
mood so English doesn't have much of a
subjunctive mood other languages do and
you use a subjunctive mood to talk about
things that you regret or things that
you doubt or wishes hopes and whatnot
and that can sometimes be an issue in
other languages not so much English
because we don't really have much of one
anymore
or we don't have a verb conjugation for
it so now I'm going to talk about a
first method that we tried now this
method was done by my team before I
arrived and it was it was a pretty
interesting method based on some prior
research so the first method that we did
was from central wordnet now sena
wordnet uses what are called cin sets
which are meanings of words in that are
they basically take our words and they
divide them into different meanings they
do some distant valuation for you in
this corpus called word net which is
available on the internet and assigns to
each word of score of on positivity
negativity and objectivity so as you can
see this diagram here we have three
points on a triangle where we have a
positive sense a negative sense and
really a non-polar sense now there's I
believe there's also a model attached to
sent a word net which I believe uses a
support vector machine we didn't use
that model but instead we used the list
of words to give to give the sentiment
for each word and then we use words like
very and to to amplify the sentiment and
words like not to flip it and we devised
our own scoring technique to handle this
and that ended up becoming the overall
score but there are problems with this
method lexical analysis such as we did
is very slow so the lexical analysis
method and sent to word net also
involved part of speech and part of
speech tagging can be very slow there
are some that are faster in Python the
one that we were using wasn't
particularly ideal and that's something
we're going to revisit later a lexical
analysis is not very accurate in this
particular case we had 65 percent
accuracy and our f1 score was 0.3 so an
f1 score is basically a balance of
precision and recall precision and
recall are two metrics that come from
information retrieval and they give you
more information than accuracy alone F 1
squared go
from 0 to 1 so 0.3 is pretty bad
additionally human judges are very
unreliable there is some research that
says that somewhere around 20 cats only
about 20% of the time the human judges
agreed with each other so this is very
problematic and also lexical analysis
varies based on language so our original
technique did not work for languages
other than English because parts of
speech are different and whatnot but
what if we use just words what if we
forget the lexical analysis part and
just use words this is a bit bold but
let's see if it works
what if we train a classifier instead
but where can we get labeled data to
train this classifier we came up with a
better way so one of the difficult
things is working with text in a
supervised fashion is that you need
label data and this is very hard to get
it must already exist it has to be
applicable to the to the domain that
you're modeling and if it doesn't exist
you need human labelers one of the
advantages of working at Facebook is
that we have millions of labelled data
points that come in every month every
day then so and the best part is they're
already tagged by the person writing the
text so we know so based on this based
on what they write they label the text
with how they feel we don't have to
guess it we lose the ambiguity ambiguity
so this is an example of some labeled
data when you write a post on Facebook
there's several different pieces of
metadata that you can add to your post
in addition to what you write you can
say where you are you can say how you're
feeling which is what we'll use or you
can say other things like where are you
currently eating lunch or something or
what are you eating so here's an example
post I'm feeling blessed blah blah blah
and a picture we also have the other
categories of these type of things as I
mentioned where you're currently what
are you eating what are you doing we're
only going to focus on emotions we took
these emotions there's a lot of them and
divided them into three groups and this
was done by myself and one other person
so one possible way to improve this is
the crowdsource it and also take people
of different cultures and and have them
agree on what these what these set of
emotions are however this is what we
have right now so positive emotions are
emotions that are most likely positive
so I'm happy we're going to assume that
there's no negativity associated with
the word happy although you can say I'm
happy that somebody failed the test or
something we're going to not we're going
to ignore that and ignore that edge case
happy is usually a good thing blessed
pretty these are all good emotions and
negative or probably negative emotions
so sad up and gree or ill then we have a
lot of nonpolar emotions and there these
are divided into several different
categories hot which I described earlier
could be a temperature or attractiveness
rating at least in English math M eh
neutral doesn't say anything or hungry
you can be positive or negative and be
hungry I'm hungry my mom is making ribs
I can't wait or I haven't eaten all day
I'm really frustrated and I'm hungry
that's not so good we can take the text
and turn it into a bag of words
representation and wrap it up with the
emotion which in this case is blest and
label it positive now we have our
training data so our experiment so some
of our results for the I'm sorry some of
the description for our dataset for our
experiments as we worked with 90 days of
data at a time and we have millions of
pieces of English content that contain
text tagged with a positive or negative
emotion for now we're ignoring the
nonpolar emotions we're only gonna do
positive or negative and millions of
total unique words can be used as
features so there's some pruning that's
involved here because you have a lot of
words that people make up you have a lot
of misspellings those kind of get
filtered out statistically fortunately
and for version one our goal is to
classify text as either positive or
negative technically speaking we're
detecting positivity so one of the
things that you have to do as a machine
learning person is feature selection so
one thing that we thought we'd try it or
one thing and the one thing that we do
is
expert feature selection so we in
features were in is in the millions may
be too many so we use chi-square to
reduce this to the top K features and
for our first version it was in the
thousands range and we raise it to the
millions range and we took features out
of confidence over 95% or a p-value of
less than 0.05 and took the top K
features of that set now there's a
better way to do this and and we'll look
we're probably gonna work on this is to
use the hashing trick which you just
hashed a bunch of feet has a bunch of
words they all map to the same space you
know the size of that feature set then
you don't have to worry about how many
features am I going to choose you don't
have to worry about how many megabytes
and gigabytes of RAM you're using
because it's fixed with the hashing
trick this also scales well with pandas
across multiple course the model itself
so is multinomial naive bayes now naive
bayes has been criticized as the
punching bag of all classifiers it's the
it's the model you use when you're just
starting and you just want to see is
there any type of signal here however
what's very strong about naive bayes is
that it works in many cases it's still
not quite known why it works in many
cases but one of the assumptions about
naive bayes is that all the features are
independent the in language this fails
miserably but miraculously it still
works pretty well so if you're not
familiar with the nomenclature on the
screen basically we have a class C which
is positive and we have a vector F which
contains feature counts and we want to
compute the product of the probability
that I've seen a particular feature
given that it's in the positive class
multiply all those together and divide
by the prior which is the probability of
a particular piece of text being part of
the positive class without any other
knowledge it's really a normalization
constant then we classify we're going to
get a probability out of this and we
classify so if we get we have more than
60% confidence that this is positive we
label a positive less than 40%
approximately we label the text negative
if it's somewhere in the middle we have
to do some more processing we're going
to say we don't know if it's positive or
negative
now there's a better way to do this and
it is to create three different
classifiers maybe to a positive
classifier and a negative classifier and
have someone samba love those two which
is something that will probably do later
in another version the best part of this
approach using bag of words and not
using the lexical features is that it
works for multiple languages currently
we support English Spanish Portuguese
Italian French German and Turkish and we
want to add Asian languages because
those are very important as well we also
want to look at is there a difference
between different locales such as
American English versus British English
is very different and and also emotions
do not translate well so that's
something that we need to visit as well
so before I go into the code in the
architecture and how this actually runs
I want to give some results which is of
course necessary for any machine
learning task so based on all the
languages you have our accuracy is
between 77 and 83 percent I showed
earlier that our accuracy with not our
accuracy that Stanford had an accuracy
of between 80 and 85 percent and that's
kind of the state of the art right now
so we're not doing too bad now this is a
range because it depends on the data use
and it also depends on the particular
language English is about somewhere in
the middle and our f1 score is between
point seven nine and point eight four
which again ranges from zero to one so
it's very high our foot we also have our
false positive rate which varies a lot
to paint on language and goes from seven
to twenty two percent in nine to twenty
four percent and for the same for
reference the original classifier that
we trained has sixty five percent
accuracy and an f1 score of only 0.3 so
this is a huge improvement so some of
you might be machine learning geeks but
this is absolutely necessary is to have
the ROC curve so basically when you get
a probability out of naivebayes you're
you would assume that well if the
probability is greater than 0.5 I'm
going to label it as part of the
positive class that's not always the
best thing to do though especially if
you have an imbalance data so what the
ROC curve does is it takes a bunch of
different thresholds not just point five
and computes the false positive rate and
true positive rate and plus them on one
plot in the absolute worst case we would
get a model that's that's along the
diagonal
which means chance of great model is
going to kind of go up the y-axis and
across the x-axis which we never see so
this is pretty good and as you can see
certain languages do better than others
so French and Italian are kind of the
weakest and Turkish miraculously is I
don't know Turkish at all is it performs
the best and apparently a wise person
told me that Turkish is a is apparently
easy to parse but I don't know it so I
have no idea Oh perfect that makes my
job a lot easier
also the precision recall curve is
another thing to look at I won't say too
much about this except that the ideal
case is where the where you have a
horizontal line at precision equals 1.0
so this is pretty good so we're at PI
data if we want to hear about the Python
behind this so what do we use for this
we use several technologies that are
either release so that we're talking
about here at the conference and that's
hive press tone data swarm data swarm
you heard more about tomorrow for a mark
Mike Starr he'll give a talk about that
and it's Python base a python-based way
to develop data pipelines and that's how
we get our data then we use pandas for
managing relational data from start to
end and gives us a nice data frame
format similar to the data frame and are
we the scikit-learn of course for the
text processing and machine learning and
we also use in ltk in the earliest
stages numpy under the hood of course
all of these are based on numpy in some
way and we assign under the hood for
working with sparse matrices also under
the hood and scikit-learn pandas provide
several things for our use case it
provides simple tabular data structures
just like in our data frame provides
fast row and column based operations
based on done by the data structures are
nearly interchangeable of numpy arrays
so you can use them with secular nasally
without any or much tinkering and it has
easy i/o for debugging very easy to
write to read write to a database or to
print to a CSV file the database support
I believe is experimental but it seems
to be getting better
wes mckinney recently came in spell
again one of the things that he
mentioned was that maybe this wooden
Banda's may not be performant for like
high-frequency trading
that's not our use case however we found
that it scales very well for our use
case so that's that's very very powerful
for us scikit-learn provides a uniform
interface for training many kinds of
models and all pointed to this in the
source code it's very easy to switch
models and experiment with different
things back in the old days before you
SEC you learned I would usually
prototype a model on a Weka which is
Java doesn't I want to say to my fellow
Weka but you can use that to experiment
with different kinds of models and then
implement them in Python it's very easy
to do that with scikit-learn though
powerful and fast vectorization of text
and it supports this is really important
critical for us it supports incremental
training as a 14-1 I believe we're on 15
15 something maybe even 16 now but
fourteen one allows you to train an
increment which means you get a batch
train a model get another batch and you
can add that to your current model and
you keep doing this and it makes
processing very scalable now I'm going
to switch gears a little bit and
describe some code it looks like I have
plenty of time about how to write and
diagnose a classifier so let's see if I
can do this without screwing this up
okay perfect
spoke too soon okay so the code for this
is very short as you can see and that's
one of the beauties of secular now
obviously in our system it's much more
complicated because a lot of
infrastructure behind this and probably
only 5% of my job is on the screen less
than 5% so first we read in data with
pandas and this is some movie rating
data and that's split on a tab space and
then we have this easy function that
actually I probably shouldn't scroll
with the screens it's the whole thing we
in the cross-validation module we have a
train test split function but lets you
set the training size or the testing
size is some proportion of the full text
and this returns you to data sets of
training to set and a testing set now if
you're using something like a support
vector machine where you have
and a gamma parameter tune you might
want to also have a cross validation set
then i vectorize the text vectorizing
basically means i take the bag of words
and i convert it into a vector that's
standardized across all of the text in
the corpus this is a huge pain in the
butt if you don't do it this way I've
had to do that it was very painful so
you're going to get a basically a very
sparse vector or matrix from this and
this is what the vectorizer does it also
removes stop words and it gives you a
count there's other types of vectorizer
as you can use as well then I'm going to
sew it below in this comment I'm not
going to actually do it or I'm not going
to actually use that as part of my
demonstration but there's a lot of other
powerful parameters that you can pass
this function you can analyze engrams
instead of just words you can set the
minimum number of times a word appears
in 1400 referred to be included you can
also set the maximum proportion of
documents that the words included in as
a form of ad-hoc form of stop word
removal then next we're going to train
we're going to fit a transform
essentially is what's called in the
secular nomenclature on the training
data which is now au which is also which
is a data frame might be an error there
and then we're going to use that here
we're vectorizing the text I'm sorry I'm
getting ahead of myself
so here we're going to vectorize the
text we're going to train the vectorizer
in other words we're going to give
different columns for each word in the
lexicon and then we're going to get at
estimate ryx which uses the same columns
the beauty of this is that's
automatically going to drop words that
did not appear in the training data so
this is another pain if you have to do
this manually you have to worry about
what words you use in the training data
that do not appear in the test data and
I have to deal with with that mess then
I'm going to take the original data so I
add a little wrinkle in here the data is
originally coded as post an egg instead
of doing that I'm going to or instead of
using that I'm going to convert it into
0 1 with a simple logic here then I'm
going to set up a multinomial naive
Bayes model now the beauty here is if I
want to change
type of model I use all I need to do is
replace this with a with a comparable
model so for example logistic regression
and maybe maybe SGD classifier will work
here some other ones may not you may
need some more parameters or whatnot and
then finally I'm going to fit the model
I'm going to fit the model on the
training data as well as the on the
training matrix as well as the labeled
the labels for each point now with the
test matrix this is a de that I want to
classify not trained so now I want to
classify some text I pass in the test
matrix and I call the predict function
on it and this is going to give me back
a bunch of a vector of predicted
sentiments and I'm also want to get the
vector of predicted probabilities this
helmet this is how I'm going to
threshold and it's also how I create the
ROC curves and the predict the predict
function will give you back the
predictions the predict probable
function will give you back the
probabilities which is really nice and
then finally you you have to of course
diagnose your classifier the first thing
that you want to do is get stay in
accuracy score so you get an accuracy
score using the score function and all
you do is you give it the test matrix
and you give it the the known labels for
those test cases and then you can
compute the precision Riko and f1 score
using this nice function precision
recall f score support now what's
beautiful about this is that computer or
a ROC curve manually it's not too bad
however I tried it and took about 45
minutes to iterate over all the
languages and iterate through all the
data instead I simply use this built-in
function that gives me back my different
error rates that I can use to compute
the ROC score and all I do is I eat
irate over the languages I took me from
45 minutes to maybe 10 seconds I'm also
I'm probably going to I won't go over
the matplotlib part because this was
used to create the graphics and it
requires a particular data set that I
can't release i might go through it if i
have time just to give you a flavor for
what matplotlib matplotlib looks like
but it's not a critical part of my talk
and if i do post the code you'll be able
to apply this at any type of data set
you might need but this just shows that
in ipython notebook I can run this code
and it will give me back a nice rocker
and a nice precision recall curve okay
so that's the hard part so it requires
me switching context switching here so
now we're going to talk about the system
architecture about how we get this to
work at Facebook basically we start with
a bunch of data of course and it comes
from a data swarm pipeline that we're
going to assume lives in the clouds live
somewhere and this gives us a training
and testing data we're going to take the
full data and split it into a training
testing set 70/30 you can experiment
with us some people like 75 50 50 is
probably not advisable but I've seen
people do it then we're going to do
feature selection Devon trained on the
data that's going to give us a model the
model can then be pickled or it can be
dumped a disk with job Lib which is an
external package within scikit-learn
and sometimes gives you multiple files
but they're right in they work
beautifully then we're going to test the
model using the the holdout set and then
we dump this data either to my sequel
for more Diagnostics or for dashboarding
so what we currently have is we
currently have based on this as a hive
transformer so I'm not a hive expert but
what a hive transformer does is just
send a script that reads from standard
in and writes the standard out and it
essentially transforms the data in some
way so we're able to write back to hive
or write back to some other data store
and we also have a thrift client or a
thrift server as to say that provides
on-demand classification and a command
line client for analysts that want to do
one-off jobs small one-off jobs so the
point of basically the point of the talk
was the following things with a ton of
self labeled data and a very basic
algorithm naive Bayes as simple as it
gets
we eliminate the need for lexical
parsing and can process multiple
languages this is very scalable and
provides us a lot of flexibility for the
future the text author is the best judge
of his or her own feelings rather than a
set of other human beings PI data
infrastructure like pandas secular numpy
Syfy and matplotlib provide powerful and
production level science and
get in so maybe if you're doing
high-frequency trading where there's a
lot of money at stake maybe you may not
want to you might find an issue with
some of these but for our use case it's
been very good it's been very very
strong friend to have so this concludes
what I had to say about sentiment
classification here at Facebook I'm now
happy to open the floor to any questions
you may have
hi oh I have a couple okay a couple
questions real quick okay um so the
first one was I noticed that you were
basically using user label data except
when I check it on Facebook I can create
my own emotions oh and I wanted to know
how you use that and then another one
slightly more technical is you mention
use chi-squared I didn't know if used
univariate or multivariate and I can use
univariate how do you handle feature
correlations mmm so to answer the first
question which was you can create your
own emotion we only take the comments
set of emotions for this particular use
case maybe we'll do we'll work with
custom ones later but we have a set of a
set of emotions that are readily that we
can readily use to your second question
about using chi-squared chi-squared is
by by nature of a double sided test
statistic and I actually tried odds
ratio which is a one-sided statistic and
found that it didn't give very good
results or feature selection accuracy
wasn't very good however I do see the
need for four to use a one-sided
statistic however for this particular
classifier a predicted positivity so
double sided was okay in our case if we
want to have a positive and negative
classifier we would have to use single
sided I did make the mistake of trying
to double sided classifier on a positive
and negative classifier and you
basically get the same results or I
should say opposite results but using
the same basic measures
um oh sorry yeah one just real quick did
you do any kind of like word stemming
for this so that that's a good question
and there's there's a debate about
stemming and whether or not it's useful
and what it's useful for a lot of
textbooks say that you should always
stem the data or state stem of the words
I personally don't do that
I think in this particular case it's
helpful to not do that especially for
other languages where you have different
verb conjugations certain words are like
past participles might have different
meanings than for example the present
indicative so I don't stem it would
reduce the the features the feature set
dramatically but I haven't found it to
be very useful that's kind of as an
engineering decision I haven't tested it
though but I'd be interested in testing
it but so far you've been looking at
single author if you look at
conversations you've been thinking about
that where you have two parties involved
we haven't really thought of that we
just we've only been using a single
author of all the sorry you guys said
that you limited the text that you were
analyzing to ones that had emoticons so
that you could be sure about that when
you set up your training what percentage
do you think of all the texts use the
emoticon so I'm curious like what
percentage of the data are you actually
you know using for your training if you
look at it and like the big picture um
that is probably something that somebody
else would have to answer I'm not
actually sure what the actual proportion
is somebody who deals specifically with
that product would probably know the
answer to that and you shown to two
methods that you try they try to make
them compete and see which one the books
better when like on what I get is it
always better there's only better
sometimes yeah sometimes honestly we
haven't we've just we basically we
looked at the judgments we feel let's
look at the judgments that came from the
original classifier and then the new
classifier and it was obvious which one
was better there may be cases and I do
suspect there are cases where lexicon
base is better than bag-of-words
but for this particular work we didn't
worry about that case for for what you
just mentioned for looking at for
looking at regiments or generically
debugging if you're looking at specific
exempt specific examples of mistakes I
hope you don't have the ability to look
at random private Facebook posts to all
what else these are public posts hey so
uh how does this problem change when
you're trying to predict the actual
state so feeling blessed versus feeling
happy versus feeling sad recession the
problem gets a lot more complicated and
I haven't had much time to delve much
into it so we've been building this
infrastructure but it's very complicated
and what I found very ad hoc is that
some emotions are much easier to predict
than others then you really get into the
case of sarcasm humor cases where people
don't say very much it's not about
signal there but they have an emotion
that is probably that might be something
that we look into but right now I don't
have too much to say about that
unfortunately once you have the train
model a model for English what ended up
being some of their features some of the
words or by grams with the highest
weights so one thing that we had to
eliminate first was all the the original
emotions so so it's trivial that the
most important features would be happy
or sad or bless we had to remove those
some of them were things like birthday
church was one God was another one was a
lot of people might use blessed and
those are kind of correlated with each
other trying to think of some of the
other ones ill I believe sick not ill
sick was one of them there was a
probably a list of about 10 that were
very high those are just some of them
did you get the sorry if you said this
did you get the same sort of accuracy
results on the Facebook posts or the
sort of traditional language wordnet set
of corpus you know like have the
language changed
so that you get different sentiment or a
more modern corpus than though oh yeah I
mean you see things that you might see
things like Yolo I mean that's not in a
dictionary maybe it is no you get
different metrics different different
scores I mean did you get different
precision different recall different
accuracy well we use a keyboard approach
are you talking about the original
method no no no your method but on
different corpus like your Facebook
corpus and the old wordnet corpus would
they can say oh so the original model
wasn't wasn't tested on the original
wordnet corpus it was tested on Facebook
public posts so uh does that answer your
question okay
a follow-up question on somewhere over
there asked if you if you basically
looked at your features that your model
selected is the most important for each
sentiment and that made you think of
your earlier slide when you added
certain words like love hate as being
generally strongly positive or strongly
negative did you experiment with using
those words in in your actual features
like if you see that word in a piece of
text market and your feature vector oh
yeah some of those words some of those
words were I love was was is a top
feature okay I don't know if I mentioned
that but some yeah a lot of the obvious
words were in the top feature list but
but I mean did you sort of try to boost
or your classifier by having like a
dictionary lookup for each input and
saying oh I found this many occurrences
of love so I'm gonna have a column for
how many times I see love not for the
current incarnation No so can you talk
up front here so okay yeah right here
okay
I just was going to ask can you give us
a sense of since this is like a machine
learning problem pretty much all in
memory how big was the server how many
features how many columns you used
because you didn't in a distributed
fashion right you had like one big
machine to pump all this data through um
yeah I can't answer specifics about like
the size of the server or whatnot but
the range I was one server it wasn't
distributed III I can't answer if
there's multiple servers or one but what
I can say is that the number of features
wasn't what was originally in the
thousands and then God was moved to the
millions and we got better accuracy that
way
uh-uh scikit-learn right that's weak
yeah okay yeah
hey just did you great search your
account vectorizer parameters at all
here did you present did you like did
you look at a couple of different and
grand ranges and whether or not to take
out your top words so engrams is
something that is not in this current
incarnation something needs to be okay
so but I mean crucially not character
engrams pluck word engrams word engrams
image it use are you just in you're just
using one word oh yeah okay this is only
on you know grams which is which is a
big limitation right now we think we'll
get an even bigger boost by using
diagrams especially maybe trigrams so
professor Chris Potts at Stanford has a
really classic example about contextual
tea so for instance if you say movie is
predictable that's bad but if a
electronic device or safety device is
predictable that's good yeah how are you
or are you dealing with context that's a
very very difficult problem and it's
definitely something that is worth
looking into this this class of our only
years it treats everything globally
have you tried um running this to local
rabbit all right here
did you try running this through vocal
babbit any idea I'm running it through
what of open rabbit uh no but I do like
verbal rabbit
so and the point of the or the point of
this talk is the Python but yeah that's
we're trying to following up on his
question how do you deal with the
phrases with the generic words like the
f-word where we you can express pretty
much everything with the f-word yeah so
the beauty of the beauty of some of
these approaches that we're using this
is that that word appears so many times
positively and so many times negatively
that it's a wash it's not a feature
because it doesn't give us any
information
it's a context specific so I mean you
know it depends but a global honorable
scale is not a feature to appear bag of
words how do you handle negations like
not we did it that's the beauty of bag
of words is that there's no lexical
structure
and we're still able to do for it pretty
good we I would like to incorporate that
somehow but for this particular work
this particular project it was just a
bag of words approach I do think that
might give us even more accuracy but
it's also a lot more complicated and
less scalable for like lol like laughing
out loud stuff like that acronyms
did you guys translate them into integer
words for class 5 no lol is this LOL its
treated as LOL as a token so someone
asked you earlier you couldn't respond
as to what percentage of like total post
head tags and i'm curious if you have a
heuristic about what words never get
tagged with an emotion and are those
things that don't have emotions like if
you post that you're in the grocery
store and you're buying lettuce like you
don't have emotion about that but that's
interesting um I haven't thought about
that that's a pretty good point I'm very
I mean my assumption is that every word
at some point this is very naive
assumption but that every word is at
some point been tagged as an emotion
across billions of users but that could
very well be wrong I haven't looked at
that yeah it's just like for example
posting that you're with your loved one
watching a movie pretty commonly going
to have a tag but if you're posting
about some complex local issue what yeah
probably not going to come up with your
target
yeah that's that's interesting I mean
for this particular classifier it'll
drop out but I am I am wondering throw
are words that have never been tagged
begging the question oh what's the use
of it so this is a hackathon project and
NLP something I'm really passionate
about I thought it was something that
was very interesting to try and we're
always looking at new variables and ways
to make the Facebook user experience
better at this time I'm not I'm not the
person to answer how it would be used
but we have the infrastructure for it
you said you use millions of features so
how sparse was your matrix Theory
anything the text is always very I mean
any number did you even go through it I
can't give you a number of the
assumptions that when working with text
it's always gonna be very sparse there
are things you could do like running Lda
or some type of cluster on the data
before training a model and that's
something that I'd like to try and then
of course it won't be as sparse and then
I would have a number for you but it's
trivially sparse
assume I've already mentioned this
before have you thought about including
other activities that might indicate
emotions such as and I guess this would
be going forward expanding on it so
checking in in a particular location or
uploading photos along with the actual
post um or even doing certain activities
like watching a movie that could
indicate so for this particular project
we're just looking at emotions that
would beg a particular use case which I
don't I don't know about yet or if there
is one all right yeah I was wondering if
you had tried handling at experimented
with handling misspelled words like
maybe looking at character engrams
thrown out character engrams that it
occurred to frequently by tf-idf yeah
and you know just trying to match that
and also sort of reduce the sparsity
that way that's a really fun problem not
for this particular incarnation maybe
some later work I've worked it on at a
previous company and really enjoyed it
but that's that's not handled in this
particular incarnation they would
probably just be dropped out especially
if it's a common misspelling like the
word commitment that that's a feature
and it's so commonly used it applies
show up as a feature as well as the
expelling but things that are rarely
someone doesn't know to spell the word
dog for goodness sakes that's probably
gonna be dropped out mmm so so so yeah
so the question was is the reason why
English may not have been as predictable
as save Turkish is that so many people
that on Facebook maybe second learners
of English uh hmm no this was just
totally global total global analysis
that would again beg for a particular
use case then we might do that but not
not for this particular work but it's a
good good suggestion and it's something
that we would look at if we were to yeah
thank you thank you for coming